with over 300 sessions at next 2018 it's
understandable you can get to them all
so if you didn't see what's new with
tons of thought then stay tuned because
here's the rewind
so what's tensor flow tensor flow is a
machine learning framework that's been
used to go hunting for new planets and
discover so the system similar tone
prevent blindness by helping doctors
catch diabetic retinopathy early and
save rainforests by alerting authorities
to science of illegal logging activity
it's what alphago and Google's cloud
vision are built on top of and it's
yours to play with tens of those open
source you can download it for free and
get started today and we've been working
to make it easier and more useful than
ever before here are some of my favorite
highlights let's start with tens of
float eager if you try tons of loon the
old days and ran way screaming because
it forced you to code like an academic
or alien instead of like a developer
there's great news for you tens of lute
eager execution lets you interact with
it like a pure Python programmer all the
immediacy of writing and debugging a
line-by-line
instead of holding your breath while you
build those huge graphs Karis plus tens
of flow equals easier neural network
construction if you like object-oriented
thinking and you like building neural
networks one layer at a time I think
you'll love TF Kerris in just these few
lines of code we've created a sequential
neural network with all the bells and
whistles new languages you asked and we
listened tens of flows not just for
Python Easter's anymore it now runs in
many languages from r2 Swift to
JavaScript and speaking of JavaScript
you can train and execute models right
in the browser with tens of Lucia's tens
of fluid light brings model execution to
a variety of devices including mobile
and IR team giving you more than a 3x
boost in inference speed up yes and how
you can get machine learning on your
Raspberry Pi or your phone see the full
talk for a live demo of image
classification on an android emulator
satisfy your need for speed with cloud
TP use if you're tired of waiting for
your CPU to finish churning through your
data to train your model you can now get
your hands on hardware especially
designed for the job and we've just
announced the v3 TP use in alpha next
make your input processing more
expressive and efficient with the TF
data namespace TF dot data gives you
fast flexible easy to use data pipelines
synchronized with training and finally
you can find and share solutions on
tensorflow hub which is a repository for
reusable pre trained machine learning
model components packaged for one line
reuse which is awesome so that's it for
my favorite highlights if you'd like to
see the full talk check out the link in
the description below and don't forget
to subscribe to the cloud YouTube
channel for more great next to mine
content thanks for watching
[Music]